Das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Derlan ist in V конце Tat.
Derlan is in V конце Tat.
Derlan ist in V schlimm,
Derlan ist in Vität,
Derlan ist in V-justum,
Derlan is in V in Simho.
Ahh, choice.
Ich wollte zwar kurz aufstehen.
Ich merke nichts mehr in meinem Hintern.
Monatliche IQ Boost, so muss das sein.
Pogu.
Exzellent.
War ein bisschen was entspannenderes als Musik.
Säck.
Top 100 Mario-Song.
Top 50? Top 100? Was hatten wir immer?
Voll.
Wir haben sogar Top 200.
Na, ob da Nintendo mit einverstanden ist?
Ich denke ja nicht.
Aber Nintendo, ich mein,
Nintendo ist eigentlich mit nix einverstanden.
Wie viele Tabs?
Na ja.
Da.
Und sicherlich
in der VM auch noch ein paar.
Ich mein,
ernsthaft, guck mal.
Ich hab
64GB RAM.
Das da unten ist das neues,
neues Feature,
Windows 11.
Ich hab 64GB RAM, irgendwo muss der Speicherplatz ja hin.
Können wir heute backseiten?
Ja, ja, ja.
Ich weiß bloß auch gar nicht, was wir machen.
Was machen wir denn heute, Leute?
Was haltet ihr denn davon?
Wir könnten uns mal wieder ein paar aktuelle Stellenanzeigen angucken.
Was da so dabei,
ob da irgendwas
bescheuertes dabei ist.
Wir können mal so auf den üblichen Seiten gucken.
Was da gerade wieder gesucht wird.
An Def bis Säck
Win
bis Ops.
Jobwechsel.
Nee, hab ich erst.
Wo haben wir denn da immer geguckt?
Admin Rockstar.
Geht schon gut los.
So, das ist immer so eine ganz gute Best-Off-Seite.
Stepstone ist ganz gut.
An Jobs.
Ähm...
Ja, LinkedIn würde ich auch,
aber bin ich nicht eingeloggt?
Kann ich mich auch nicht einloggen, weil ich das Passwort nicht mal weiß?
Also, keine Ahnung.
Leute, lasst uns mal kurz
ein bisschen was entspannteres suchen.
Komm, wir machen noch ein bisschen Wub Wub Wub an.
Ist mir eigentlich egal.
Hauptsache,
wir haben's noch gechillt.
Wub wub wub wub wub.
Dann Streamtitel ändern?
Ja klar.
Können wir machen,
ja icherdere.
Ja, richtig
Das geht exklusiv, Leute.
Nur hier könnt ihr Twitch Prime benutzen.
Irgendwo anders geht das nicht, nur hier.
Sollte man vielleicht öfters mal erwähnen, ja.
World Exclusive.
Was machen wir denn für ein Titel
für den Stream?
Stellenanzeigen Review.
So ein blödes Emoji dahinter, so.
Perfekt.
So.
Magst du ans Trinken?
Tatsächlich sollte ich machen, ja.
Du hast heute eine neue Stelle
unterschrieben, als was?
Ja.
Progo Subscription.
Übrigens,
euch fällt vielleicht auf,
vielleicht, vielleicht wundert
ihr euch, wie ich es hingekriegt
habe, dass der Chat wieder funktioniert.
Was meint ihr?
Was hab ich gemacht, dass der Chat wieder
funktioniert? Ansonsten war ja immer
das Problem, dass es, kann ich euch zeigen,
wenn ich hier Incognito
aufmach,
dann kam immer so ein Overlay.
Dann kam so ein Overlay.
Eingeloggt.
Richtig.
Das Banalste überhaupt.
Ich hab mich eingeloggt.
Aber nicht
mit meinem normalen Wubblos-Account,
mit irgendeinem Fake-Account.
Ich habe irgendeinen Fake-Account erstellt.
Stell E-Mail-Adresse weitergeleitet
von einem meiner 30.000 Bromains.
Und
ja, Fake-Account erstellt.